Bonjour à tous
Bonne année
Euh... Oui, bonne année, enfin on est déjà en février quand-même…
Alors aujourd’hui un épisode un peu spécial, vous n’avez pas pu le manquer,  on en a parlé partout sur les réseaux sociaux il y a quelques semaines
De quoi ? Les vacances de Blanquer à Ibiza ?
Quoi ? Mais non je parle de l’anniversaire de la mort de Pierre Bourdieu.
Mais non mais personne parle de ça !
Mais si ! Je pouvais pas faire un tour sur Facebook ou sur Youtube sans voir un truc sur le sujet !
T’es sérieux ?
Ben oui ! L’humanité à même fait un numéro spécial sur le sujet et sur le neurchi de pierre bourdieu et ses amis à l’hexis corporelle distinguée ça a pas arrêté !
Ben je crois qu’on a pas le même internet !
Peut-être qu’on n’évolue juste pas dans le même champ
C’est une ref à Bourdieu c’est ça ?
Pardon je voudrait pas que tu sente dominé par mon capital culturel, mais là c'est mon habitus qui me titille
Oh oh oh je te prévient on va se calmer tout de suite parce que je vais pas tenir une vidéo entière comme ça là !
Oui tu as raison.
Donc Pierre Bourdieu est mort à 71 ans le 23 janvier 2002 et donc le mois dernier ça faisait tout pile 20 ans qu’on déplorait sa mort.
C’est l’occasion de lui rendre un petit hommage et de revenir dans les grandes lignes sur la figure incontournable qu'est ce grand monsieur de la sociologie.
Générique
Alors c’est toujours compliqué de revenir
en quelques minutes sur une personnalité
aussi complexe et foisonnante que celle de
Pierre Bourdieu.
C'est est une figure incontournable de la
sociologie et on compte aussi bien des
adorateurs béats qui le voient comme un messie,
que des critiques acerbes qui l’accusent
d’avoir fait plus de mal que de bien à la sociologie.
Du coup, bien modestement, parce que je suis loin d’être un spécialiste,  je vais essayer de mettre un petit coup de projecteur sur sa vie, ses inspirations théoriques, son œuvre,
et ses engagements à la fois politiques et scientifiques.
Comme je viens de vous le dire, je suis loin d’être un spécialiste et en plus j’écris
cette vidéo assez vite parce que j'essaie de coller encore un petit peu dans l’actualité
donc je ne m’interdis pas éventuellement de refaire un petit sujet hors-série pour repréciser certaines choses notamment peut-être pour
développer un peu la postérité qu'il a eu dans les différents courants sociologique.
Donc si vous m’entendez dire une énormité ou
au contraire oublier un point qui vous semblerait crucial, surtout n’hésitez pas,
l’espace commentaire est là pour vous.
Dans le respect et la bienveillance par contre
ça va de soi !
Partie 1. Sa vie
Alors la vie de Bourdieu est intéressante
parce que sa sociologie va être considérablement
influencée par des trucs qu’il a lui-même vécu.
Par exemple quand il invente le concept de violence symbolique dont j’ai  déjà parlé dans cet épisode, ben c’est quelque chose qu’il a directement ressenti  lui-même.
Bon. Et dans l'éventualité où on se remate pas tes vieilles vidéo tout les deux jours, la violence symbolique… tu nous refait un petit topo.
Ok. La violence symbolique c’est une forme de violence indirecte, qui n’est pas perçue directement mais qui est exercée par les dominants sur les dominés
parce qu’ils sont plus légitimes qu’eux, même si Bourdieu
insiste sur le fait que c’est souvent pour des raisons complètement arbitraires.
C’est l’exemple du type qui dans un dîner mondain te demande quelle est ton oeuvre de Céline préféré
et que tu te doutes que sous le vent avec Garou c’est pas vraiment la réponse attendue.
Et bim violence symbolique dans ta face.
Et Bourdieu il a vécu de première main cette
violence symbolique parce que lui il vient
d'un petit village rural des Pyrénées-Atlantiques,
son père c’est un petit fonctionnaire des P.T.T.
et après le lycée, comme il était bon élève,
il va être bombardé en classe préparatoire
à Louis-Legrand à Paris, après
il va rentrer à l’école normale supérieure
et là il va côtoyer que des gens qui viennent
plutôt d’un milieu social et intellectuel
élevé et il expliquera qu'il s'y est jamais
vraiment
senti à sa place, d’où se ressenti de
violence symbolique.
Et même jusqu’à la fin de sa vie en fait
il continuera paradoxalement à faire preuve
d’une certaine timidité alors même qu’il
est clairement l’ultime beau gosse de sa discipline.
On le voit très bien dans le film de pierre
Carles, La sociologie est un Sport de combat
sorti en 2001 qui s’ouvre sur une prise
de parole que Bourdieu doit faire en anglais
et il est littéralement paralysé par le stress.
c’est dûr là, mais c’est affreux d’avoir le trac comme ça…
Mais ça c’est l’insécurité linguistique
ça redouble.
On le verra mais Bourdieu n’hésite jamais à faire sa propre auto-analyse et le concept  de violence symbolique semble bien rendre compte de son sentiment d’illégitimité
qui peut se manifester parfois par des sensations
profondément viscérales.
« Quand on vient d’un petit milieu et d’un pays dominé, on a forcément de la honte  culturelle, moi j’avais la honte de mon accent que j’avais corrigé etc. je suis
passé par l’école normale, quand je descendais dans mon pays, ça Pierre Carles va très bien comprendre, quand j’arrivais à Dax
que j’entendais l’accent ça me faisait horreur mais vraiment horreur.
Mais encore aujourd’hui quand j’entends certains accents à la radio ça me fait physiquement horreur. Alors que c’est l’accent que j’avais.
A la radio j'entendais Tillinac, qui est un
écrivain chiraquien, qui parle avec l'accent de Brive,
j'ai envie de le tuer, voilà, ça me fait horreur !
Pas seulement par ce qu’il dit,  alors ça
voilà c’est une forme de violence symbolique»
Ouhlà il a des petits soucis d’agressivité le père Bourdieu non ?
Non mais je peux comprendre.
Moi aussi ça me fait ça quand j’entends
certain politiques parler,
Gerald Darmanin par exemple
Mais à cause de son accent ?
Ah Non rien à voir c’est plutôt à cause de son….
Et de ses….
Disons que c’est plutôt plus un tout quoi.
« Non mais calmez-vous madame ça va bien
se passer »
Vire-moi ça, sérieusement, je commence à
faire de l’urticaire !
Après l’école normale notre Piérot national
va passer l’agrégation de philosophie,
c’est le concours pour devenir professeur
et il commencera par enseigner au lycée avant de devoir partir faire son service militaire.
Et il faut dire qu’à l’époque on est en plein pendant la guerre d’Algérie alors
ça rigole vraiment pas avec le service militaire qui peut durer jusqu’à 30 mois.
Il sera affecté au gouvernement général
d’Alger et c’est pas du tout anodin dans
sa biographie parce que c’est en travaillant
sur place avec des statisticien de l’Insee
qu’il va bifurquer vers la sociologie en se formant à l’ethnologie et au travail d’enquête.
Il va même rester en en Algérie pour poursuivre
ses études entre 1958 et 1960 en faisant
beaucoup de travail de terrain Il publie ainsi
son premier livre en 1958 "Sociologie de l’Algérie"
dans la collection Que sais-je, et il reviendra
sur le sujet en 1964 avec "Le Déracinement,
la crise de l’agriculture algérienne" coécrit
avec le sociologue Abdelmalek Sayad, et encore
une fois plus tard en 1972 sa fameuse "Esquisse d’une théorie de la pratique précédée de Trois études d’ethnologie Kabyle".
Alors l’expérience algérienne n’est
absolument pas anodine dans la vie de Bourdieu
parce que la Kabylie va continuer toute sa
vie à nourrir son œuvre, depuis l’étude
comparative qu’il fait en revenant dans son village natal du Béarn
jusque dans ses écrits tardifs comme la domination masculine en 1998 dans lequel il analyse les rapports symboliques entre les hommes et les femmes
aussi bien dans notre société que dans la société
traditionnelle kabyle.
Et il faut aussi souligner que le contexte d’apprentissage du métier d’ethnographe en condition réelle va lui apporter très vite une grande expérience de l’enquête de terrain.
«ça a été redoublé par expérience de l’Algérie
où j’ai fait des enquêtes en situation
dangereuse… où oui, je pense que ça m'est
arrivé 2 ou 3 fois, selon la réponse que je donnais je pouvais m’en tirer vivant ou mort.
Selon la manière de poser les questions etc.
Je n'avais pas d'autre protection dans une
situation de guerre civile, de guerre de libération,
je n'avais pas d’autre protection que ma
bonne tête, et ma manière de me présenter, de faire attention...
Et ça je crois que ça m’a beaucoup appris.
Il y a beaucoup de chose qu’on lit dans
les livre de méthodologie…
ou qu’on ne lit pas dans les livres de méthodologie…
car évidemment l’essentiel n’est pas dit.
Et bien je l’ai appris comme ça… et ça,
ça met du plomb dans la cervelle (…) j’ai vieilli très vite.
Par rapport à un jeune sociologue qui aurait
fait sa petite enquête peinard sur les profs (…)
et du coup j’ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de problèmes, qui sont sorti de là.
J’ai vécu en gros sur le capital de problèmes
que j’ai ramassé à cette époque-là,
je crois que ça ça a été important.
Et évidemment je vais rajouter ça comme
ça pour votre truc ce sera très bien, c’est
que j’ai eu l’idée, comme je travaillais
sur la Kabylie et que je voyais beaucoup d’analogie
avec le Béarn, les structures familiales,
les rapports entre les sexes etc.
Je me suis dit, pour ne pas utiliser mon expérience
de manière sauvage, il faut que j'aille étudier
mon village comme j’ai étudié la Kabylie.
Alors j’avais 2 objectifs, d'abord de contrôler
cette expérience,
et puis aussi aussi d’étudier ce que c’était
que de passer de l’expérience indigène
à l’expérience savante, qu'est-ce que ça fait ?
Et je disais à l’époque, c’était l’époque
où Lévi-Strauss avait fait Tristes Tropiques
c’était le livre que tout le monde lisait etc.,
moi j'ai dit je vais faire Tristes Tropiques à l’envers,
c'est-à-dire je vais faire un retour,
au lieu d’aller chercher très très loin,
je vais chercher chez moi le moins
exotique possible, je vais rendre exotique, le banal.»
Comme vous pouvez le voir il se pose déjà
plusieurs questions épistémologiques sur
la façon de passer de l’expérience au
savoir sociologique et c’est aussi une question
qui va l’accompagner tout au long de sa vie.
Alors la fin de sa vie je vous la fait courte
mais il va publier près d’une soixantaine
de travaux sociologique dont certain vont
être des blockbusters aussi bien dans le champ académique
que pour un large public et sa notoriété de va cesser de grandir
jusqu’à ce qu’il occupe la chaire de
sociologie au collège de France de 1981 à 2001
soit pratiquement jusqu’à sa mort.
La fin de sa vie va également être marquée
par un engagement militant de plus en plus prononcé
et lui qui refusait plutôt de s’exprimer
sur la place publique va faire de plus en plus
d’apparition à la télé, même si parfois c'est
sans grand enthousiasme
« Vraiment, je peux vous dire, ça paraît étonnant,
je n’avais aucune envie de venir ici... et j'y viens »
Il a d’ailleurs pas mal été critiqué pour ça mais ça j’y reviendrait un peu plus tard après avoir fait un petit détour par son travail en commençant par ses maitres à penser.
Partie 2. Ses inspirations
Tout d’abord Bourdieu il a bien lu ses classiques
de la sociologie et il va s’inspirer de trois figures principales
Marx, Weber, et Durkheim.
Alors déjà à Marx il va emprunter la vision de la société comme étant le théâtre d’une lutte entre des groupes sociaux aux intérêts antagonistes.
Marx voyait tout l’espace social selon la seule dimension économique avec d’un côté les capitalistes qui possèdent les moyens de production
et de l’autre les prolétaires qui n’ont que leur force de
travail.
Bourdieu reprend ainsi l’idée d’une société comme un espace de lutte pour la domination,
à la différence près qu’il va représenter l’espace social sous plusieurs dimensions
et ça il va plutôt aller le chercher chez un autre sociologue allemand : Max Weber.
Pour Weber il y a trois grandes catégories de stratification sociale, il y a les classes sociales sur le plan économique,
les groupes statutaires qui dépendent du prestige social et les partis qui permettent l‘accès au pouvoir politique.
Et ces 3 dimensions ne se recoupent pas complètement.
On peut avoir beaucoup d’argent et pas de prestige, ou beaucoup de prestige mais pas de pouvoir politique, ni spécialement d’argent.
Un grand écrivain ou un universitaire par exemple,
il a un statut élevé selon l’ordre social, mais bas selon l’ordre économique ou politique.
Et du coup Bourdieu va reprendre cette analyse-là pour développer la notion de champ qui est sans doute l’un de ses concepts les plus connus.
Il emprunte ici le vocabulaire de la physique,
l’idée d’un champ magnétique,
pour montrer que les individus sont tous pris dans des rapports de dominations dans plusieurs champ sociaux différents.
Contrairement à Weber qui voyait 3 ordre hiérarchiques,
pour Bourdieu il y a un très grand nombre de champs
et on n’a pas besoin des mêmes compétences pour être dominant dans le champ des tradeurs de cryptomonnaie que dans le champ… grégorien
T’as vu j’ai fait un jeu de mot avec champ/chant
Dèjà que tu nous parle de trucs un peu abstrait
s'teuplé, évite d'en rajouter là !
Ça va. Mais c’est pas la seule chose que Bourdieu va retenir de Weber et il va aussi prolonger  sa réflexion sur le pouvoir et la domination.
Weber avait fait une typologie des différentes formes de domination (charismatique, traditionnelle  ou rationnelle légale)
mais il avait surtout montré que les rapports de domination sont aussi des rapports de sens, qui sont perçus comme légitimes par les acteurs.
Et Bourdieu il va notamment beaucoup s’interroger
sur les notions de légitimité culturelle
et sur pourquoi on accepte comme légitime
la culture des catégories dominantes.
Et finalement Bourdieu va également lire avec attention le père fondateur de la sociologie  française à savoir Emile Durkheim.
Alors il s’inspire de Durkheim à la fois pour son raisonnement holiste,
à savoir pour le fait qu’il considère que les structures
sociales s’imposent aux individus,
mais aussi pour sa méthode telle qu’il l’a
énoncé dans les règles de la méthode sociologique
en 1895.
Comme Durkheim, Bourdieu a une vraie prétention
à l’objectivation et veut faire de la sociologie une véritable science.
Dukheim insistait par exemple sur l’importance
pour le sociologue de se défaire des prénotions,
c’est-à-dire des jugements de valeur qu’on peut avoir sur tel ou tel phénomène pour  les analyser avec une certaine froideur scientifique.
Et de la même façon Bourdieu et Passeron
quand ils écrivent "Le métier de sociologue" en 1968
insistent notamment sur la nécessité pour le sociologue de rompre avec le sens commun en disant qu’il faut pour cela faire preuve d’une grande
vigilance épistémologique constante pour ne pas se laisser contaminer par les préjugés qui viennent de la société.
« Et alors plus profondément c’est tout l’ensemble des schèmes de pensées qu’utilise le sens commun pour rendre compte de ses expériences sociales
que le sociologue risque toujours de laisser s’introduire dans sa science et par exemple dès le vocabulaire, charrie tout un ensemble de présupposés sociologiques,
le sociologue doit donc opposer une vigilance particulière contre toutes les infiltrations du discours commun et de l’expérience commune du social ».
Alors si on peut trouver aisément tracer des lignes de filiations entre Bourdieu et  ses prédécesseurs, l’une de ses particularités
c’est qu’il fait an fait assez peu référence aux pères fondateurs de la sociologie et il  donnera au contraire souvent l’impression d’avoir tout trouvé tout seul
et même d’être un peu le seul à faire de la vraie science.
On peut comprendre que ça ait énervé certain de ses détracteurs, d’autant qu’il pouvait faire preuve d’une certaine arrogance sur le sujet,
comme on peut entendre dans cet extrait de radio.
« Etant entendu que quand je dis sciences, je dis que on peut me réfuter avec des arguments scientifiques.
Jusqu’à présent j’ai été l’objet d’attaques… mais jamais de réfutation au sens rigoureux du terme.
Et je dirais que l’une des raisons de ma tristesse c’est que dans le champ intellectuel français j’ai beaucoup d’ennemis mais je n’ai pas d’adversaire,
c’est-à dire des gens qui feraient le travail nécessaire pour poser une réfutation.
Je sais que à Paris IV on me répond "mais ça c’est totalitaire, puisque vous êtes  irréfutable", pas du tout !
Pour me réfuter il faut se lever de bonne heure, il faut travailler… »
Et Zbam !
A ouais clairement le mec se prend pas pour la queue d’une cerise.
Effectivement non, après on peut pas le reprocher de ne pas travailler.
Et justement, c’est ce qu’on va voir maintenant.
Partie 3. Son travail
Bon alors vous vous en doutez mais je vais pas pouvoir vous résumer 40 ans de travaux sociologiques en 5 minutes
Du coup je vais simplement essayer de retracer dans les grandes lignes quelques ouvrages et quelques concepts principaux.
Pour Bourdieu, la sociologie est une science qui doit expliquer le monde social
mais qui  doit aussi avoir pour but de dévoiler les rapports de domination qui existent dans le monde.
Mais il va s’intéresser en détail à un type de domination bien particulier qui n’est pas la domination économique ou la domination politique
mais qui est c'est ce qu’il appelle la domination symbolique.
Et ça il l’étudie principalement à travers le fonctionnement subtil des inégalités face à la culture.
Il le fait d’abord dans le livre "Les Héritiers"
en 1966, puis dans "La Reproduction" en 1970
qu’il coécrit tout les deux avec Jean-Claude Passeron et dans lesquels ils étudient en détail le fonctionnement de l’école et de l’enseignement supérieur.
Leur analyse part d’un constat qui peut paraître trivial aujourd’hui mais qui l’était beaucoup moins à l’époque, à savoir que bizarrement,
les enfants issus des classes dominantes, ils ont beaucoup plus de chance d’accéder à l’enseignement supérieur que les enfants issus d’un milieu populaire.
Etant donné que tous les élèves vont dans la même école républicaine et qu’ils ont accès au même savoir,
tout le monde devrait avoir les mêmes chances de réussir, donc cette répartition inégale des places dans l’enseignement supérieur paraît à première vue inexplicable
Les voies du seigneur sont impénétrable.
Et pourtant notre Piérot va réussir à percer les voie du seigneur parce qu’il va parfaitement réussir à expliquer le phénomène.
En même temps il s’appelle Pierre Bourdieu.
…
Pour résumer en 2 mots Bourdieu et Passeron montrent que l’école n’est pas le lieu de la méritocratie et de l’égalité des chances qu’elle prétend être
parce qu’elle valorise un certain type de culture : la culture légitime.
Et c’est précisément cette culture que les enfants de bourgeois, enfin pardon, les héritiers, côtoient déjà à la maison.
Et surtout les sociologues insistent sur le fait que l’école ne donne en fait jamais vraiment toutes les clés nécessaires à la réussite scolaire, autrement dit
la réussite scolaire repose en grande partie sur des implicites.
"tu crois être en train de respirer de l'air"
C’est vrai que ça nous est sûrement tous arrivé de nous trouver face à un contrôle  qui pose des questions complètement différentes de ce qui a été vu en classe,
et du coup ça, ça valorise forcément ceux qui n’ont pas que l’école comme pourvoyeur de culture  légitime.
Et à l’inverse, les enfants issus de milieu populaire sont entièrement dépendant de  l’école pour réussir parce que leur famille ne peut pas leur apprendre  ce que l’école ne leur dit pas.
"Oh bon Dieu ! Vous sentez bon la pomme de
terre."
Bourdieu s'est d'ailleurs engagé pour une pédagogie explicite visant à expliciter  tous ces petits sous-ententus de l'institution scolaire.
Pour donner quelques exemples les implicites à l’école primaire se situent souvent  à l’échelle de la métacognition,
c’est-à-dire que le bon élève, quand on lui donne un exercice, il comprends à la fois la consigne, mais il comprends aussi ce que le professeur essaye d’évaluer avec cette
consigne.
Par exemple dans ce petit exercice où on demande de colorier la moitié des voitures en rouge,
l’enfant qui a l’habitude de ce type de consigne comprend qu’on essaye d’évaluer sa capacité à compter et à diviser par 2,
voire éventuellement de visualisation dans l’espace et il fera quelque chose comme ça, comme ça ou comme ça.
En revanche, l’élève qui suit la consigne à la lettre mais qui a moins l’habitude des devinettes ou simplement moins l’habitude de se demander
pourquoi on lui pose cette question, parce que dans sa famille on prend rarement le temps de lui expliquer les règles,
pourra répondre comme ça, et là c’est une vraie réponse d’élève que j’ai trouvé sur le site copie-double...
on voit que c’est parfaitement juste, mais que ça manque un peu l’objectif de l’exercice qui, lui, est implicite.
Un autre exemple sur les formes de consigne, là on voit que l’élève répond directement à la partie « qui suis-je ? »
sans faire le lien avec ce qui précède. Pourtant je suis persuadé que suis on lui avait demandé une question du type ……… – 3 = 8
il aurait pu trouvé le chiffre manquant. Et là on voit que la différence entre l’enfant qui réussit et celui qui ne réussit pas ça se joue pas tant
sur les capacités mathématiques que sur : est-ce  qu’il a déjà entendu une formulation sous forme de devinette à la première personne avec une question « qui suis-je ».
Donc la vrai question c’est : est-ce que ses parent lui font des devinette ? lui lisent des histoire ?  lui offrent des carambar ? bref,
l’ont déjà familiarisé avec ce type de questionnement avant.
Je vous mets quelques autres exemples d’erreurs qu’on peut trouver par manque d’explicitation, et si au primaire ça reste encore assez évitable,
je vous laisse imaginer au collège et au lycée quand il y a des exercices de plus en plus complexes, avec des exigences parfois de moins en moins explicites.
Bon et après c’est justement pour essayer d'expliquer ce phénomène de culture mobilisable comme une ressource
que Bourdieu va fonder le concept de capital culturel en empruntant là une métaphore économique pour montrer que la culture peut elle aussi être un capital
qui permet d’accéder aux places les plus valorisées.
La vision la plus abouti de ce raisonnement sera publié en 1979 dans "La Distinction, critique sociale du jugement", mais qu’il écrit cette fois sans Jean-Claude Passeron
- Bon Pourquoi tu fais la gueule encore
- Je fais pas la gueule j’en ai juste marre d’être toujours dans ton ombre Pierre !
C’est vrai les gens ne me connaisse pas, dans la rue il m’appelle « l’ami de Bourdieu » c’est insupportable.
- Allons Jean-Claude arrête je vois bien que tu fais la gueule, tu fais la gueule depuis  "La Reproduction".
Je t’ai déjà dit que si tu travaille dur et que tu te lèves tôt toi aussi tu sera un grand sociologue, tu verras.
Ah oui et aussi pas de sucre dans mon café,
ça aussi je te l’ai dit plusieurs fois.
Bon, du coup c’est tout seul que Bourdieu s’atèle à l’écriture de "La Distinction"
et pour vous donner une petite idée du retentissement que ça a eu l’Association internationale de Sociologie l’a désigné en 1998
comme l’un des 10 livres de sociologie les plus important du 20ème siècle.
Au côté, au hasard, de "l’éthique protestante et l’esprit du capitalisme" de Weber, du "Processus de civilisation" de Elias
ou de "la construction sociale de la réalité" de Berger et Luckman.
Donc autant dire pas des petits clodo !
Et dans son livre, Bourdieu va s’efforcer de faire une cartographie de l’espace social  par le prisme de la distinction au travers des jugements de goût.
« Quand nous mettons une cravate à pois ou une cravate unie, quand nous achetons une Mercedes ou une deux chevaux,
nous nous identifions plus profondément à nos goûts, au fond, qu’à nos opinions, et nos goûts nous trahissent beaucoup plus profondément que nos opinions. »
A partir de là Bourdieu va produire sa fameuse classification de l’espace social en deux dimensions que tout les étudiants en sociologie connaissent
et où il classe certaines pratiques et professions selon en fonction d’une quantité de capital culturel et économique.
On voit par exemple que les professeurs ont beaucoup de capital culturel mais peu de capital économique
et que ici par exemple la chasse est davantage pratiquée par ceux qui ont beaucoup de capital économique mais peu decapital culturel, et qui votent plutôt à droite.
- Il faut avoir une âme de poète pour être chasseur ?
- Ah Putain ! C'est Essentiel !
- Ah faut être pouet !
Et ce que montre Bourdieu c’est que non seulement on s’identifie assez fortement  à nos goûts et à nos jugements,
mais que tout le monde est plus ou moins directement conscient de l’échelle des légitimités culturelles.
Même si on adore Harry Potter, on sent bien que c’est pas la réponse attendue dans un dîner mondain si on nous demande quel est oeuvre littéraire préféré.
Et c’est bien parce qu’on sait que certains goûts peuvent être illégitime qu’on a justement peur de faire des fautes de goûts.
« Une de mes découvertes en travaillant sur ce sujet c’est que aujourd’hui il n’y a surement
pas beaucoup de jugements qui engagent autant les gens que les jugements de goûts,
vous pouvez facilement faire rougir quelqu’un… aujourd’hui, le faire rougir sur sa sexualité ça devient de plus en plus difficile
mais faire rougir sur une faute de goût, sur une gaffe, ça c’est extrêmement facile,
et c'est une des difficultés de l'enquête parce que, évidemment le rapport d'enquête est un rapport social, et la personne interrogée à une idée du statut social
de la personne qui l'interroge, donc de ses goûts, de ses préférences, et il a peur d'être jugé par l'interrogateur».
Et de fait bien souvent, ce qu’on appelle le « bon gout », c’est le goût des classes dominante.
Et pour montrer que nos goûts sont profondément intériorisés au point d’être des supports de notre identité, Bourdieu va fonder le concept d’habitus,
qu’on a lui aussi déjà vu dans une vidéo précédente.
Attend... c’est pas le machin avec la définition
imbitable ?
Imbitable non, c’est simplement un « système de dispositions durables, ensemble de structure  structurée prédisposées à fonctionner comme des structures structurantes,
c’est-à-dire en tant que principe générateur et organisateur de pratiques et de représentation qui peuvent être objectivement adaptées à leur but
sans supposer la visée consciente de fins et la maîtrise expresse des opérations nécessaires pour les atteindre,
objectivement « réglées » et « régulières » sans être le produit de l’obéissance à des règles et, étant tout cela, collectivement orchestrées
sans être le produit de l’action organisatrice d’un chef d’orchestre ».
Bourdieu, Le sens pratique
« Je comprend rien »
Je me sens pas bien là... je me sens pas bien, je crois que ça m’a
physiquement donner envie de gerber…
Ça fait toujours ça quand on n’a pas l’habitude,
mais tu verras on y prend goût.
Je me permet d’en douter !
Donc en français ça donne quoi ?
L’idée c’est simplement que quand tu évolues dans le monde social tu hérites  d’un certain nombre de dispositions, de façon de parler, de façon de se tenir, de manger, de
travailler, de te divertir et même de voir le monde qui dépendent de ta classe sociale, de ton genre, de ton lieu de vie, en gros de tes conditions objectives d’existence.
Et comme ce sont des dispositions dont tu
hérites, tu peux aussi les transmettre.
C’est pour ça qu’il parle de structure structurée prédisposée à fonctionner comme structure structurante.
Par exemple si tu apprends par ton papa qu’un homme viril ça doit jamais pleurer ni exprimer ses sentiments
et que cette disposition est renforcée par les tes copains, tes modèles masculins, et tout les film que tu vois,
et bien tu va intégrer ce comportement à tes façon d'agir, dans
ton habitus,
aussi bien dans tes façon de penser, que dans tes façons d'agir parce que du coup dans ta tête un homme qui pleure ben ce sera une mauviette.
"Personne ne me traite ... de mauviette"
Et puis en ayant ça dans tes gestes et dans ta tête, tu participes inconsciemment à  la reproduction et à la diffusion de ce schéma de penser et d’agir.
Après je peux aussi ne jamais pleurer sans pour autant considérer que les hommes qui  pleurent sont des mauviettes.
Personne ne me traite de mauviette Needles,
personne !
Oui c’est possible d’avoir un habitus dissocié, mais en général les deux vont de pair.
En fait Bourdieu distingue deux dimensions à l’habitus, il y a d’un côté l’Ethos,
qui désigne les principes et la morale qui façonnent ton habitus,
et de l’autre il y a l’hexis corporelle qui correspond aux postures, et aux dispositions du corps qui ont été intériorisées au cours de ta vie.
Et l’habitus c’est à la fois la grille de lecture  à travers laquelle tu comprends et tu juges la réalité, mais c’est aussi le producteur de tes pratiques,
et les deux sont en fait assez indissociable, parce que toute nos actions ont quand-même pour nous un certain degré de cohérence,
même si c’est pas toujours conscient.
Et évidement, ce que montre Bourdieu c’est que nos habitus dépendent aussi en grande partie de notre classe sociale, c'est pour ça qu'il parle d’habitus de classe.
On n’a pas la même façon de parler, de manger ou de se divertir selon sa classe sociale mais on n’a pas non plus la même vision du monde
ou les mêmes jugements esthétiques parce que l’habitus c’est un ensemble structuré qui a quand-même une certaine cohérence au sein de chaque espace social.
« Toutes les choses qui sont mentionnées là-dedans, vont très bien ensemble.
C’est-à-dire que le fait de préférer telle ou telle cuisine n’était pas sans  rapport avec le fait de préférer telle ou telle musique (…)
Alors on retrouvera tout un ensemble aussi de choses parfaitement cohérentes entre elles  et tout à fait exclusives des préférences tout à fait voisines ».
Et c’est là toute la thèse de "La Distinction", c’est que dans cet ensemble de goûts, de mode d’actions et de façon de voir le monde cohérentes entre elles et dont on hérite
à travers notre habitus, on observe bien souvent des logiques qui vise à se distinguer les uns des autres, et en particulier de ceux qui sont les plus proches de nous,
comme les bobo écolo qui font tout pour se distinguer
de la vieille aristocratie économique
"Les brunch sans Quinoa ! Quinoa !"
Habitus, un parfum de distinction.
Et tel le parfumeur qui ne confondrait jamais de la lavande fine avec de la lavande aspic, ou du lavadin Grosso, ou encore
l’une des quarante autre variété de lavande qui existe sérieusement ! je pensais pas demander un truc compliqué en cherchant de l’huile  essentielle de lavande !
Bref.
Et bien il faut être prudent avec la classification des pratiques sociales parce que comme l’habitus désigne aussi une façon de voir le monde,
ça veut dire qu’une même action peut avoir des sens très différent selon l’espace social dans lequel on évolue
et même si on est persuadé d’être ultra-original, ben on reproduit bien souvent des stratégie parfaitement explicable à l’échelle de notre champ social.
« Et par exemple le fait de revenir aux blue-jeans
ou de revenir à des choses apparemment populaires
change complètement de sens quand le oui
est un non nié, quand c’est une double négation.
La deux chevaux de l’intellectuel n’a rien à voir avec la deux chevaux de l’ouvrier agricole.
Je dis que les gens sont infiniment moins
libres qu’ils ne le croient. »
Alors on lui a beaucoup reproché d’avoir une vision de trop figée de l’espace social avec des structurent qui se reproduiraient à l’identique
et qui rendraient impossible le changement social.
C’est ce qu’il appelle l’Hystérésis de l’habitus
Personne ne me traite de mauv... Bonk !
Du coup il a par la suite beaucoup insisté sur le fait que l’habitus est quand-même  une structure assez plastique qui va se modifier tout au long de la vie
au fur et à mesure qu’on fait de nouvelles rencontres, et de nouvelles expériences.
Et en parlant sa propre expérience il en est arrivé à la notion d’habitus clivé,  c’est-à-dire de personnes qui ont plusieurs habitus qui coexistent en eux
comme lui qui a abandonné son accent et son habitus de classe pour adopter l’ethos de l’universitaire intellectuel.
Par exemple on peut imaginer que si on passe suffisamment de temps dans un contexte de pandémie on va acquérir de nouvelles habitudes sur les façon de parler,
de se saluer, de se rencontrer et même de porter le masque.
On aurait des façon de porter le masque qui seraient socialement situées et qu'on utiliserait pour se distinguer les uns des autres.
Du coup ça devient en quelque sorte du coronabitus ?
Tu sors !
Du coup on commence à avoir fait un bon tour d’horizon de la sociologie Bourdieusienne avec les notion de violence symbolique, de champ, de capital, d’habitus,
on voit qu’il met réellement au point tout un attirail conceptuel qui lui permet de penser le monde social.
Mais il y a un dernier concept que je trouve assez important à évoquer parce qu’il  va concentrer une bonne partie des critiques et c’est la notion d’illusio.
Il peut pas dire "illusion" comme tout le monde ?
Non, c’est bien illusio… mais… Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Je t'ai dit de sortir mais pas littéralement ! Revient on n’a pas fini.
Ben t’es pas assez explicite ! bon ce que je disais c'est : pourquoi il dit pas juste « illusion », il est vraiment obligé de créer encore un mot compliqué ?
Oui c’est vrai qu’avec l’habitus, l’illusio, l’ethos, l’hexis,
Bourdieu il aime bien emprunter son vocabulaire au grec et au latin
mais c’est justement pour bien marquer une frontière nette entre le sens commun d'un côté et le langage sociologique de l'autre.
S’il avait dit habitude, illusion, morale et position on aurait pu trop facilement les  confondre avec le sens de tout les jours
alors que lui justement il veut en faire des concepts précis
avec une définition précise.
Mouais… et du coup c’est quoi cet illusio ?
Alors l’illusio c’est le fait d’être pris par le jeu social et de croire qu’en  fait il vaut la peine d’être joué.
C’est en fait l’idée que les individus ne savent jamais vraiment quel sont les véritables  déterminants de leurs actions parce qu’ils sont pris dans le jeu,
ils sont la tête dans le guidon, au beau milieu des mécanisme sociaux.
Par exemple un enfant de bourgeois peut être persuadé que s’il a eu la mention très bien au bac c’est parce qu’il a bien travaillé
et donc qu'il ne doit sa mention qu'à son mérite personnel.
Et en fait on voit qu'il a tout intérêt à conserver cet illusio parce que justement  cette croyance lui permet de se valoriser.
« Et par ailleurs moi j’ai fait des études de sociologie alors ça te calme hein la sociologie parce que moi quand je suis arrivé à la fac j’étais convaincu
que j’étais très méritant et très fort et puis j’ai découvert les travaux de Bourdieu,  "La reproduction sociale", je suis tombé de ma chaise
et j’ai compris que ben non j’avais juste eu de la chance »
Et en fait, Bourdieu montre que l’illusio c'est justement ce qui permet à un champ  social de se constituer :
le champ du scientifique, le champ de l’entreprise, le champ de l’art. A chaque fois on fait comme si toutes les règles au sein de champ étaient complètement justifiées
et n’était pas qu’un assemblage socio-historique de jugements plus ou moins arbitraires.
Par exemple pour qu’un artiste soit prêt à consacrer des heures à son art et à persévérer malgré la difficulté et l’échec
il faut bien qu’il soit persuadé que l’art est la chose la plus importante dans la vie, c’est la condition même de l’engagement au sein du champ.
- So What do you do ?
- I am the future of modern theatre Scott
Et de fait c’est difficile de réussir pleinement au sein d’un champ si on garde une distance  critique,
c’est pour ça que pour bien jouer le jeu, il faut qu’on oublie qu’on est en train de jouer un jeu.
- that guy is hilarious
En d’autres termes, on s’aveugle volontairement et on refuse de voir la réalité sociale dans laquelle on est inséré.
Donc l’illusio c’est à la fois une contrainte, mais aussi quelque chose qui nous arrange  bien parce que c’est ce qui permet de donner du sens à notre vie
si on se pose pas trop de question.
Et pour Bourdieu, la sociologie permet justement de lever le voile de l’illusio et révèle ainsi aux individus la véritable signification de leurs actions.
« La sociologie a une fonction je crois importante, elle dérange par définition puisqu’elle  dévoile et qu’en dévoilant,
elle dévoile comme toute science, il n'y a de science que du caché etc. et en dévoilant elle rend plus difficile le fonctionnement de certains mécanismes.
D’autant plus que ces mécanismes ne marchent complètement que si celui qui en bénéficie ne sais pas complètement qu’il en bénéficie »
Mais ce positionnement ça va aussi avoir des effets très concret sur la façon de  Bourdieu de se placer en tant que sociologue.
En fait pour lui, le sociologue ne doit jamais
écouter les justifications des acteurs sociaux
parce que, ben justement ils sont pris dans l’illusio, donc ils ont forcément une vision partielle de leurs actions,
et c’est au sociologue qu’il revient de leur révéler leurs  véritables sens, sans se laisser polluer par le sens commun des gens qu’il interroge.
Et d'ailleurs pour Bourdieu si les acteurs sociaux pouvaient se taire un petit peu et arrêter d'essayer sans cesse de s'auto-analyser, ça lui ferait des vacances.
« Oui je crois qu’il faut pas hésiter à dire, que c’est peut-être la malédiction de la sociologie d’avoir affaire à des objet qui parlent »
Et cette position elle va aussi lui être abondamment critiquée parce que ça place  le sociologue dans une véritable position de démiurge qui vient
révéler les ficelles du monde social là où les agents seraient nécessairement aveugles aux rouages de la société, et donc au véritable sens de leurs actions.
C’est notamment sur ce sujet qu’un sociologue comme Luc Boltanski, qui est lui-même un  ancien élève de Bourdieu, va rompre complètement avec lui
en soutenant qu’il faut écouter les justifications des acteurs. Il écrira d’ailleurs "De la justification" avec Laurent Thevenot qui vient juste d’être  réédité.
Cela dit, pour Bourdieu, tout son travail doit servir politiquement, il fonde ce qu’il appelle la sociologie critique,
qui vise à dénoncer les mécanismes sous-jacents et inconscient de l’exploitation et cela va se ressentir dans son engagement politique.
C'est ce qu'on va voir maintenant.
Parties 4. Ses engagements politiques
Bourdieu n’est pas seulement un universitaire et un intellectuel, il s’est aussi beaucoup engagé politiquement.
En cela il reste fidèle a sa vision de la sociologie comme d’une science du dévoilement  qui sert à révéler les rapports de domination, dans l’espoir  pour lui de faire changer la société.
Donc son engagement commence par faire de la bonne sociologie et pour lui la sociologie doit s’adresser à tout le monde pour permettre à tous de s’émanciper.
C'est ce qu'il énonce si bien dans le film
de Pierre Carles
"- Je dis souvent la sociologie est un... est un sport de combat, c'est un sport de combat ça sert surtout...
La sociologie c'est un sport de combat ?
Oui c'est un sport de combat car comme dans les sports de combat on s'en sert pour se défendre, essentiellement
Et on n'a pas le droit de s'en servir pour
faire des mauvais coups.
Et il a en grande partie réussi à faire cela parce que ses livres ont été de véritable succès et ont circulé dans toute la population.
Ce qui, au passage, est quelque chose que je ne m’explique pas complètement tant Bourdieu a une écriture imbitable…
je veux dire, je comprends pas comment on peut vouloir propager ses idées au plus grand nombre
et écrire comme si on était payé au prorata de virgule au mètre carré.
Peut-être qu’il est né trop tôt, il aurait
juste dû être Youtubeur en fait.
T'es pas riche ducon ! Tu vas pas devenir riche parce que justement les riches tout l'argent il l'ont eux ! Et ils le donnent à leurs enfants ! Tu peux pas l'avoir toi !
Bref,
on peut dire quand-même dire que de ce côté-là la sociologie de Bourdieu à porté ses fruits comme peut le montrer l’ouvrage "Pierre Bourdieu, L’insoumission en héritage"
paru au Puf en 2016 avec les contribution d’Edouard Louis,  de Didier Eribon et d’Annie Ernaux qui ont tous connu une ascension sociale semblable
à celle de Bourdieu et qui racontent en quoi la lecture de la sociologie Bourdieusienne a été une libération pour comprendre leur propre expérience, et notamment les
phénomène de violence symbolique et de sentiment d’illégitimité qu’il n'ont pas manqué de ressentir dans leur parcours.
violence
violence sociale
brutalité extrême
Une bonne illustration de l’impact qu’a pu avoir Bourdieu pour un grand nombre de  gens peut se voir dans le film de Pierre Carle
quand il se fait alpaguer par une militante au sortir d’une manifestation
"Moi je vis exactement ce que vous écrivez et puis j'en finis pas depuis 15 ans alors à des moment j'adore, je vous dois un grand merci,
et à des moments je suis énervée contre vous
Et oui il y a de quoi je comprends
En tout cas j'ai une grosse passion et puis bon tout ce qui se dit maintenant que vous êtes tellement médiatisé ça m'énerve tout ce qui se dit autour de vous
médiatisé non, insulté par les médias oui !
il y a quinze ans je me rappelle quand je disais Bourdieu personne connaissait et maintenant  c'est d'un ridicule de dire Bourdieu
enfin c'est drôlement intéressant pour vous d'analyser ça sûrement aussi"
Mais pour ce qui est de l’engagement en tant qu’intellectuel, on peut clairement  distinguer deux périodes dans la carrière de Bourdieu.
Au début, il s’opposait notamment à la figure de Sartre qui était un peu l’idéal-type  de l’intellectuel engagé à l’aura messianique et capable de répondre à tout.
Il prônait au contraire une intervention des intellectuels beaucoup  plus parcimonieuse
et surtout des interventions davantage fondées scientifiquement et portant sur des sujets beaucoup plus précis.
« On ne peut plus répondre à tout, il faut répondre à des questions partielles, délibérément  constituées comme partielles, mais y répondre complètement,
enfin aussi complètement que possible dans l’état des instruments de connaissance.
Et cette et cette sorte de redéfinition minimisante de l’entreprise intellectuelle est je crois très importante parce que c’est un progrès dans le sens
d’un plus grand sérieux à la fois scientifique et politique. »
Mais à partir des années 1990, il va s’engager sur de plus en plus de terrains
et on peut finalement se demander s’il va pas finir par se rapprocher justement de la figure messianique de Sartre.
Luc Boltanski utilise l’expression d’ « Agit-Prop » pour désigner le Bourdieu de fin de vie, qui prend part à tout les combats et qu’il accuse de pratiquer
une forme de terrorisme intellectuel à l’Ecole des Hautes Etudes en Science Sociales L'EHESS où il essaye d'un peu tout contrôler.
C’est vrai que même s’elle est parfois réévalué aujourd’hui, la fin de carrière  a été pas mal désavouée, notamment le pavé "La misère du monde" sorti 1993 fera
très polémique dans le champ universitaire.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’on a fait au Bourdieu ?
T’es vraiemnt sûr de cette vanne là ?
Attends qu'on se mette bien d'accords : moi je suis juste là pour faire des blagues quand tu commences à raconter des truc chiants,
après mois j’ai aucune obligation que ce soit des bonnes blagues.
…
"Et bien nous quitterons la salle, nous n'avons
rien à faire dans cette justice"
En fait, je crois que la date pivot pour comprendre cela est peut-être 1984 qui voit la mort de Michel Foucault, emporté par le virus du Sida.
J’ai l’impression, et cette analyse ne m'est d'ailleurs pas personnelle,  que c’est à la suite de sa disparition que Bourdieu va endosser, presque malgré lui, le costume de l’intellectuel engagé.
Et qu'il commence ainsi à prendre la parole sur des sujets de plus en plus divers et qu’il  ne maîtrise pas parfaitement, en justifiant
cela par le fait que si lui ne le faisait pas l’espace serait rempli par d’autre  personnes qui en connaissent sûrement encore moins que lui sur le sujet.
"Tout en disant que je n'était pas détenteur de la vérité absolue sur ce mouvement, j'ai essayé de dire ce qui m'apparaissait être le sens de ce mouvement.
Pour une raison simple c'est que je savais que d'autres le diraient  et qui étaient encore plus mal placés que moi."
L’image la plus connue est sans aucun doute en 1995 quand il prend la parole au mégaphone lors de la grève des cheminots contre le « plan Juppé »
et qu’il se lance notamment dans un discours d’amour au service public et à la main gauche de l’Etat qu’il  estime mise à mal par les réformes gouvernementale.
- Mais pourquoi vous avez fais ça ? Etre là ? Encourager ?
- Oui pour encourager parce que, parce que je pense que c'était un mouvement intéressant, je voulais être là.
Il mourra finalement le 23 janvier 2002 à l’âge de 71 ans d’un cancer généralisé  des poumons
et il laissera derrière lui plusieurs œuvres inachevées comme un ouvrage sur Manet qui sera finalement publié en 2013
ainsi que son "Esquisse pour une auto-analyse" qui était pratiquement finie celle-là et
sera publiée dès 2004.
Depuis 2015, on assiste à une publication de ses cours au collège de France qui sont reconstitués à partir de sources multiples
(parce qu’il n’étaient pas tous facilement accessible en vidéo comme maintenant)
ce qui montre que Bourdieu n’a pas fini de faire parler de lui.
Conclusion
Alors. J’aurais pu m’attarder plus longuement sur les critiques qui ont été faites à la sociologie de Bourdieu,
ou au contraire sur les ramifications fécondes qu’ont pu avoir ses notions de champ, d’habitus, de capital culturel,
mais peut-être vaut-il mieux aujourd’hui essayer de dépasser l’opposition un peu vaine entre les pro et les anti-Bourdieu.
- je suis désolé on a un débat intellectuel ce soir effectivement c'est-à-dire qu'on réfléchit ensemble (...)
C'est pas compliqué de se mettre dans une salle et de se payer Bourdieu, et de s'en
faire une médaille ensuite.
Qu’on le veuille on non, Bourdieu a eu un impact considérable sur notre façon de penser le monde et cela se retrouve jusque dans les mots qu’on utilise pour y réfléchir.
Vous ne parlez peut-être pas tous les jours de votre habitus clivé ou de l’hystéresis de votre hexis corporelle,
mais fort est de constater que de nombreux termes Bourdieusiens font désormais partie du langage courant, ou à tout le moins du langage militant.
Les notions de capital culturel, de doxa, de violence symbolique, de champ social sont effectivement très souvent réutilisées,
au point d’ailleurs d’en être parfois complètement réinterprété et vidé de leur sens initial,
et à titre personnel je me réjouis qu’un plus grand nombre de personnes ait eu accès aux armes permettant d’analyser le monde social.
Le sociologue Benard Lahire a écrit ce 23 janvier une tribune dans l’Obs intitulée « Aimez-vous Bourdieu ? »
dans laquelle il nous exhorte ne pas muséifier Bourdieu, aussi bien pour en faire l’éloge que pour en faire la critique, et je rejoins à 200% son analyse.
Il est sûrement temps aujourd’hui de dépasser Bourdieu, mais pas pour le ringardiser, mais au contraire pour continuer l’exploration du monde social
qu’il a entrepris jusqu’au dernier jour de sa vie.
Et terminerait ainsi en citant directement le texte Bernard Lahire :
On pourrait s’inspirer de l’attitude critique et créatrice qui fut la sienne face aux traditions scientifiques présentes dans sa jeunesse, parmi lesquelles, le structuralisme anthropologique incarné par Claude Lévi-Strauss.
Comme le disait Gaston Bachelard dans « la Formation de l’esprit scientifique », un philosophe auquel Bourdieu aimait se référer :
« Dans l’œuvre de la science seulement on peut aimer ce qu’on détruit, on peut continuer le passé en le niant, on peut vénérer son maître en le contredisant. »
- En fait j'ai deux mythes vivants c'est Cavana
et Vous. Chacun dans leurs...
- Oh un bisous ! Je veux la caméra !
- Adieu.
Cet épisode de SocioClassic est maintenant terminé j'espère qu'il vous aura plu. N'hésitez pas à laisser un commentaire pour me dire ce que vous en avez pensé.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner, d'activer la cloche pour être au courant de toutes les actualités.
Pour suivre l'actualité au jour le jour il
y a bien sûr la page Facebook.
D'ailleurs je ne vous en dit pas plus mais il va y avoir des actualités très prochainement donc restez connectés !
Et je vais profiter de cette fin de vidéo pour faire quelques petites recommandations si vous voulez en avoir plus
sur Pierre Bourdieu il y a bien évidemment plusieurs manuels, plusieurs ouvrages  qui en parlent très bien.
Il y a ce petit manuel de Bernard Lahire, sur la sociologie de Bourdieu qui est très bien fait.
Mais j'aimerais en profiter pour mettre un peu de lumière sur la chaîne de Grégoire  Simpson.
C'est une chaîne YouTube de vulgarisation sur le raisonnement sociologique et on y parle pas mal de Bourdieu
notamment d'un travail que j'ai pas du tout abordé ici à savoir des "Méditations Pascaliennes".
Mais aussi pleins d'autres travaux de Bourdieu.
Et sa chaîne est absolument un bijoux c'est une de mes dernières découvertes absolument fantastiques. Allez-y sans hésitation.
Si en plus vous vous intéressez au travail de Pierre Bourdieu il en parle avec beaucoup justesse en allant vraiment dans le détail.
C'est vraiment très très bien fait. Donc allez-y ! Foncez sur la chaîne de Grégoire Simpson !
sImpson ? sIMpson ? Je sais pas comment ça se prononce....
Sinon voilà je pense qu'il me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter une excellente année 2022.  Comme je vous ai dit j'ai prévu de faire un peu plus d'épisode que l'année précédente.
On commence par une grosse vidéo et il y en a plusieurs qui devraient arriver bientôt.
J'essaie de rester sur ce rythme-là.
Je vous fais des gros bisous et à bientôt.
Ciao !